this is napoli attack and six months ago
i used one of them to chase tom all the
way across london and i came very very
close to finding so close you've got the
air tag this time i'm tracking you we're
on your home turf in nottingham yes the
rules are roughly the same you've got a
list of tasks you get a point for each
one you complete your job is to beat my
seven tasks from last time
my job is to tag you first okay
one hour all right air tag it's going in
the pocket
list of tasks is on our phones we
haven't read it yet yes one hour
that doesn't seem like a lot of time
good luck aaron your time starts in
three two one go okay see ya
and i'm going to keep looking this way
i've just got to stand next to the wall
here now and just not look at anything
i've got five minutes now
at the very least i can outpace tom
let's see what we've got
airtight rematch okay now i need to pull
up this list of tasks where do i need to
go
oh now i know how tom felt my god take a
trip to the oldest in england right
that's the old trip to jerusalem i know
that so that might be somewhere worth
going oldest in england
i know where that is these tasks are
much less location specific a lot of
these could happen anywhere so one of
the rules of this game is that i can
only take every form of public transport
once
gotta be very tactical about this
in theory i could just
sit by the robin hood statue for for 45
minutes but he could just see me and run
and get everything everywhere else in
fact if he's aiming right for the robin
hood statue he's either going to get it
very quickly so i can't possibly catch
up with him
or he knows i can wait from there so
that would that would be a bad move on
his part find a piece of art to be
honest there'll be a piece of art in any
building
yeah that counts right
i think my only option is to actually
track him with the air tag so i think i
just got to wait out the five minutes
see where he's going
which is really stressful i was really
hoping to plan ahead here i'm just gonna
text him to tell him we've done one and
we've only had four minutes
one
he's already completed task i haven't
even set off yet what could he have done
within three minutes of here what i'm
going to try and do is to complete the
less specific tasks on the way to the
more specific tasks so let's try and
find a gift for tom
i mean the gift could be anything
if i don't get an airtight update then
my only option in 26 seconds time
is to run for the robin hood statue and
just keep checking in and hope he's gone
that way i i've had no update from the
air tag chop chop shop shop shop okay
there's a tesco across the road
aha i forgot to turn my food on airplane
mode
no
ah three two
one i'm gonna try and follow him so the
way these air tags work is they send out
a bluetooth signal that's picked up by
nearby iphones and it's those iphones
that then beam the location to the
internet so the fact that i've had my
phone's data on this whole time is not
good okay we went the right way we went
the right way i've got an update he's
this way
[Music]
two he's got a second task already
right
the statue he must have posed with the
statue here he knew where the statue was
i didn't that's home turf advantage
he's got to run that way at some point
he's got the old trip to jerusalem down
there which is the oldest pub
and he's got the robin hood statue
i've got no other updates
we gotta we gotta head that way
robin hood statue
okay
does that go on
yes okay
so
oh now i've got to text him three wait
there's another thing i can do here
anyone who thinks that an air tag is a
good real-time tracker
absolutely not okay
i found another statue
what are you doing
[Music]
does that count
okay
cool
not what i thought i'd be doing today
let's go he's already on three it's what
10 minutes in he's already on three i'm
nowhere near him
find my
what
that can't be right i need to text him
for
i need to get some cover because he's
definitely coming this way
there's no way he doesn't know where we
are i've got i've got no idea where he
is was he hidden in a doorway or
somewhere back there and saw me run
[Music]
no good at stealth
four we need to go back to town center
now
well we need to take a route that we
know avoids tom
ah
it's infuriating this is absolutely
infuriating the air attack just is
not
tracking him okay i think our best bet
is to go the opposite way he would
expect us to go jump in an uber and use
that to get past him going back
no update is eight minutes come on this
is meant to this is meant to do better
than that
gotta turn my data back on
anxiety and juicing
i'm just i'm just force closing and
reopening fine mind i hope it it forces
an update from something
okay taxi is
three minutes away
can we oh jerusalem in this is the
oldest pub
[Music]
so let's take a trip to the oldest inn
in england
okay here we go good trip
[Music]
he hasn't got any tasks in a while
let's look at the list what's he what
will he have got fine timepiece five
okay i've just texted him five while
we're in the oldest inn there's no way
he doesn't know where we are right now
oh god
i'm hyper paranoid right now every
single person who's walking past i'm
like double checking to see if it's tom
we got an update he was
what
nine minutes ago he was heading down
that way he's on a bus
or he's on a tram
headed
to nottingham castle he's got to be
going for the robin hood statue he's got
to be we've
i've got to run to the robin hood statue
it's the only option i've got
which is this way you ready for an
uphill run we're going to a castle so we
are 14 minutes in we've already done
five of the eight tasks this feels good
he must be panicking right now
if this is a wrong bet
i'm done for
thank god okay we're okay
okay i'll get on the other side
okay
we got our car
he went this way i know he went this way
because
12 minutes ago the air tag pinged
where we were by the statue
ten minutes ago it pained somewhere on
the street
we are in our car there is no tom to be
seen
yet i just told me that i'd left aaron
behind somewhere
damn right i did
that's a statue
we are headed to these shops
so i'm gonna try and get a change of
clothing and
i also need to dance with a busker which
i can safely say i've never done before
four minutes ago he was
up there
he was up there he was coming for the
statue
[Music]
has he made it here yet
so at this point i'm now going to turn
my airplane mode on update dammit so tom
will think that this is the last
location we're at right now we're about
to leave him behind and go into town
come on airtag
i should have run here
i had the plan i was gonna run here
right away
i thought no i'll wait for the air tank
tracker this is thrilling
oh i'm an idiot
the old trip to jerusalem the pub
the oldest pub
is just up there
and that's exactly where his air tank
was five minutes ago
and i was so fixated on the statue i
didn't think to check that location
so i've only really got two tasks i can
do in town which is going to take us to
seven i need to make sure i know what
the eighth is gonna be he can't be
coming for the statue if he was this
close he would have got the statue by
now so where's he going instead
list of tasks
[Music]
welcome to nottingham
why haven't i seen an update where could
he have gone
if he's down nottingham caves i'll be
very impressed you must be thinking
where are they
i mean if it's any consolation
i imagine he'll be panicking i'm right
behind him
and uh
yeah no what's helping this time is that
it is a smaller city and you're spending
less time in transport
although it doesn't really feel like it
right now
let's head back towards the town centre
he either he's got these or he's not
getting these if i head back towards the
town centre chances are i'll be closer
to wherever the next ping is
who knows
this clothing task is probably going to
be one of the longer tasks but
if i change my outfit that is going to
guarantee my safety it's not giving me
any information right now
how can he not have done a task
in like 10 minutes where is he going
what's he doing
is he
is he in a cab is he on a bus
good to go okay let's find a shop how
has he avoided all people with iphones
for 11 minutes
unfortunately we are gonna have to go
right into the center of town to get an
outfit which is gonna expose us but i'm
hoping that uber ride through tom off
hello and welcome to 20 minutes of tom
looking down at his phone confused
if you want to take your career in a new
direction then you may want to have a
look at this video's sponsor boolean in
short they'll teach you to code boolean
are a career focused tech academy with
live online classes their courses last
between 10 weeks and 6 months full-time
or part-time you can choose between
front-end development full stack or data
analytics and the final classes of the
year are starting soon on november the
7th it's designed to start your career
which means there's a heavy focus on
practical work during the course their
teachers are people who've done the job
and have industry experience plus you
have the option to pay only when you
actually get hired at the end of the
course or if you pay up front you're
covered by their refund guarantee if you
apply to jobs and don't get hired
they'll refund you so if you're
seriously considering taking the next
step in your career and joining a
fast-growing industry like tech you may
want to consider signing up for
boolean's last cohort of the year and if
you start the application process before
30th of september they'll also give you
a 500 pounds early bird discount there's
a link on screen in the description good
luck for your future
right
back to me chasing aaron in nottingham
it's been 15 minutes since aaron did a
task one two three four five they all
went really really quickly they went
within nine minutes of each other and
now it's been 15 more minutes
and he's not take a single one off
and
i'm
this way
i was right
heading back towards town was the right
thing one minute ago he was round that
corner one minute ago come on come on
come on i'm getting so scared right now
heading right into the middle of town
this is not good
okay i just need to slip into this shop
here
i want to buy myself the plainest outfit
possible this will do very nicely
almost camo i'll be invisible
let's get
extra extra large
if he did a task
around this corner i headed up
that's fine just those are great yeah
thank you so much
no i'm being chased
for a challenge okay it's unsafe i
promise he was right here
he was exactly here
two minutes ago do you guys have a
changing room yeah you do okay fantastic
i'm still whispering because
for all i know it might be down one of
these alleyways
god okay i've gotta change fast
i'm very vulnerable when i'm stuck in
this store
you know what i said
he was right there
the tag moved while i was talking to
camera the tag moved he's down here
he's just down here
all right i'm in the changing room
you're probably not going to want to
watch this
okay i'm done i look ridiculous right
now
he was here
[Music]
just realized i also need a hat
that will do the trick
get a hat as well if he
tripped the air tag got a task over
there
avoided people
sent me on a wild goose chaser here and
is now running to the castle i swear
yes i'm being chased yeah
who's chasing you
uh it's a youtuber
i'm gonna take a punt
i'm gonna head down to the broad marsh
which is like the one bit of nottingham
i remember
because i've been there as a kid i'm
gonna head down towards the broad marsh
in the hope that he went vaguely this
way let's get that one
all right i look ridiculous you look
amazing oh thank you okay
is he here did you see him
you look very scared right now can we
get out of here
aaron is either a tactical genius or
he's just randomly panicking and running
places
and i don't know what the
roadmarsh is gone
number six is done
just texted tom which unfortunately
means he's now gonna have an update on
where we are okay
what next well okay didn't expect to
have my childhood wrench from me uh here
but we move on uh
allen's not on the broad marsh
it's six
that challenge took longer than expected
we only have 25 minutes left to do the
final two
[Music]
i also have a suspicion he's very close
i'm gonna head vaguely this way
which is back towards the castle i know
we were there earlier gotta get off
these main roads asap
if aaron's smart and he is
then he will be
quietly wandering around nottingham with
a smile on his face and a game plan for
his last two tasks
knowing that i'm in the dark only
suspecting him in the dark he will be
going stealthily he will be looking over
his shoulder he'll be sneaking down back
alleyways
hopefully we can get up there we'll get
a view of the windmill
[Music]
we're youtubers
i think he said what are you doing
okay yes i think we can get a stained
glass window in here
there was a new tag four minutes ago
back where i
if i'd have just stayed there
ah my hat
that's not par
none of this makes sense
[Music]
take find a stained glass window okay i
mean
that counts right
cool
seven
he's not gonna be happy about that
seven
that's it he needs one more task to win
with time to spare
i don't have the faintest idea where he
is i think when i get up here i'll be
able to see the windmill
i really hope sick
oh
no there's a giant building in the way
no
surely not
surely not
oh no
no
[Music]
ah
student accommodation
that way he's gone that way
but
but that was four minutes ago
we're very exposed on this road there's
not a lot of people but on the plus side
that should mean the air tag will ping
less because there's less iphones we're
passing
he was right here
five minutes ago
[Music]
i'm trying to actually use the thing
that uh
that searches the air tags actual signal
but he's not anywhere around here
i know it's that way you just can't see
it
he's nowhere near shakespeare street
he's nowhere near the robin hood statue
he's nowhere near the oldest in england
i think he got all those before i got
there
i really want to turn on google maps so
i can check
but then tom
then tom will be right on to me with
like no escape he'll know exactly where
i'm going
yikes he's that way
he's that way five minutes
it's so frustrating if these were live i
might stand a chance but okay my data is
now on i'm exposed let me just quickly i
need to quickly check this windmill if
he got on a tram i'm done for
i'll never catch him
all right final sprint i'm pretty we're
nearby now
oh i ran the wrong way that's helpful
he didn't go this way he went that way
if i'm really lucky i can cut him off
down here but it's just gonna be luck
i know i've said this like four times
but i'm pretty sure next corner we turn
there will be a windmill
we're back here again we're back at the
crossroads we've just
looped round in a figure eight chasing
shadows
chasing minutes old shadows oh god as
well as my date has been on this entire
time why do i keep doing this am i just
getting ice
cream come on
come on
windmill
yes yes i see it
okay
second place
okay
selfie selfie
oh god
oh god
okay we need to get closer
this is
heart-wrenching stuff
[Music]
come on
[Music]
yes
okay that counts right here
that's the windmill that's the wind now
ah
redemption feels so good
okay
let's give tom a ring
is that eight
that is eight thomas
i never stood a chance i never stood a
chance
oh
well done also uh nice hat
um thank you
do you want to come and meet me by st
peter's church and uh
i'll see you in a minute yes yeah sure
okay see you there
he's changed
at least one item of clothing
possibly two
i wonder if i was anywhere near him
here we go here we go
do you like my get up i mean
good hatch with this on yeah yeah i no i
can't believe it you can even actually
invert it
and that's time like yeah chimes the
bell
i
had two problems one is that there were
like 10 minute gaps where i just saw
nothing i had the same thing in london
but also when it did update it said five
minutes ago yep from there it just
i got a flurry of updates within a
couple of minutes just all around this
area and i like looped around three or
four times
interesting there
so
i'm going to put this camera down
because on camera i've got something to
show you oh no no no no no no no no you
do
so the fantastic getup that aaron
managed to get is from that shop there
from blacks
i was stood there
i know you stood there because while he
was in blacks
i got this footage of you two
wait the two cameras saw each other
that's fantastic oh here's your gift by
the way i brought you tingly mint and t3
champagne
thanks it's been a hot day today thanks
yeah
well done eric good game let's go to the
pub